the winters are long in Kiruna in
Sweden's high north but the workers
can't wait till the snow melts they're
already tearing down buildings in the
youth spit on quarter we're mainly
families with children once lived
at the fence Aoife and Kalyan McKee
watched the demolition machines with
mixed feelings the neighborhood that was
their home for decades will soon cease
to be it's a bit sad building something
is one thing but tearing it down is
something else again it feels terrible a
phone call Johan came here almost 40
years ago with temperatures outside
reaching below minus 40 degrees Celsius
in winter their apartment often took on
the character of a refuge for 35 years
it was our castle our fortress our two
children grew up here the ore mines
operator the state-owned LKAB has found
a new apartment for the couple the
mining town of Kadena once the world's
largest municipality has a population of
over 23,000 the first houses were built
here over a century ago right on top of
some of the world's biggest known iron
ore deposits people here say the mine is
qu Donna trains kilometers long
carry the or over to Narvik the nearest
ice-free port on the Norwegian see what
danger the ore mining poses for the town
became apparent about 10 years ago when
giant cracks appeared in the ground the
decision was made to move the entire
town urban planner you are on cash
helped to design the new queue Donna
he's well aware that he and his team are
effectively throwing people out of their
homes but he says there was no
alternative
we've chosen to move the city two and a
half kilometers eastwards to build the
new one here because the new districts
will be able to incorporate the outlying
areas not endangered by the cracks and
we believe this area is safe so the city
won't have to move again
Coronas
old wooden church will also have to move
your Akash explains that it's always
been the heart of the town part of the
lives of many of its residents this
church is our most valued structure
it'll have to be dismantled piece by
piece and rebuilt every single part has
to be marked very carefully that's
absolutely vital
not far away is another of the town's
institutions but it's doomed to
disappear the Sparta Buuren the black
bear restaurants miners and other
townspeople have gotten together here
after work for years if a manky enjoys
the hearty cuisine and generous helpings
as restaurant was alive when I first
came to carry on in 1974 dr. st. day
it didn't look exactly like this back
then but I remember we always came here
for lunch
Oh God sandwiches for breakfast here not
good even more of so the black bear is
part of kyriaki nakeeran ah sweat WN but
this is one tradition that may soon come
to an end this is a working man's diner
I don't know if this kind of place will
fit into the plan to new city centre
besides the rents will be a lot higher
there
mayor to Patterson doesn't know what
she'll do once the restaurants gone and
the wrecking ball won't be long in
coming the colossal project is scheduled
for completion in 2033 at a total cost
of 320 million euros
that might sound expensive but it's
worth it because the iron ore still in
the ground promises enormous returns for
decades to come
municipal representative gunas el bag of
the center party doesn't agree with the
plans to move Cunha he says much of the
ground set aside for the new town might
be contaminated after the open is McGill
weekend the city used to be a few
factories where they want to build the
town and also a mine with a slurry Basin
to catch the drainage water pumped out
might contain heavy metals like arsenic
cobalt nickel and other hazardous
substances it falling gunas el bag is
among the very few who've criticized
plans for the move most of the residents
stand behind it more or less a fan Karl
Johan Mickey have already moved into
their new place and a development on the
edge of town it's bigger and not that
much more expensive they say we've got
to say how big an apartment we wanted
and where and the mining company tried
to take our wishes into account whatever
it depended on how long you've worked in
the mines they say it'll take a while to
settle into their new home and their new
town it'll help when their neighbors
start to move in from the old Karuna
you